love this man i consider him a great
friend not just because he and his wife
are wonderful people but because uh we
spent some time together back in the day
at espn and ever since he is the voice
of college football essentially and also
he did an outstanding job as usual
hosting the heisman trophy ceremony over
the weekend he's my buddy chris fowler
here in the mercedes-benz vans phone
line on the rich eisen show how are you
doing chris oh you flatter me rick you
showered me with love like come on here
it's the truth right back at you these
are all these are all truthful
statements hashtag truth um so uh let's
get right into it um with with that
ceremony over the weekend uh bryce young
was remarkable this year just remarkable
um do you think the uh the writers got
it correct in the the trophy award yeah
i mean writers and others i mean i i
think that look he had something like
684 first place votes and hutchinson
which by the way is a tremendous job to
finish second in the heisman as a
defensive player had 78 so it was a
landslide that i've never seen you go
from like wide open to landslide it
reflects like
2021
kind of lightning bolt speed that things
move at right we went from like wide
open race all of a sudden and bryce
knows he was a long shot and they're
losing to auburn right and in their last
regular season game they're down to
auburn they're going to be knocked out
of the playoff that the offense has
three points
he goes down there accounts for all 97
yards on the game time drive wins it
over time and then dominates georgia and
all of a sudden he goes from being in
deep trouble to a landslide that's how
fast things happen this year
yeah and then we're showing the final uh
vote uh on the screen i'll be honest
with you i don't know if it's because
hutchinson is so big i i didn't know
bryce young was so slight you know
right startling yeah when you see a
quarterback listed at six foot you
always know that's a fudge right again
probably five ten like nobody wants to
be five something right in terms of
quarterback height but but that makes it
all more remarkable what he's able to do
to be a the number one recruit
in the country at
undersized he's he sort of makes light
of that i mean no one doubted brycen was
going to be a great college quarterback
by the way and everybody knew he could
play but he doesn't fit the prototype
and thankfully the prototype is
expanding and changing uh you know in
part because of guys like baker and
kyler who's going to you know be in this
game tonight and others have sort of
reshaped what prototype is but he is i
would say 510 maybe and very slightly
built like he knows he's got to get
stronger a little sturdier he doesn't
take a lot of hits because he's so
smooth and they pretty much protect him
well for the most part this year and
he's so instinctive and elusive but he's
not
powerfully built which is uh something
you'll probably want to add a few pounds
but it's remarkable his vision all the
other intangibles he's got him and his
his ability to uh to just be so cool and
calm under pressure yeah and we'll get
to the games uh that are still remaining
for the college football playoffs in a
second with you chris fowler here on the
rich eisen show we'll get to that in a
second couldn't help but notice uh jim
harbaugh had great seats behind third
base uh on saturday night uh chris
are you saying he should have been
sitting fine on plate or something no no
no no no
i'm just saying he was right behind ryan
day who he said uh
i think it was to the ohio state coach
he was alluding when he said after the
victory over ohio state that some people
are born on third base and think they
hit a triple so that's what i'm
referring to oh now i get it now i guess
yeah i don't think we gave a lot of
thought to that i tell you what um
you know it was sort of like a little
celebratory for michigan because they
did get the w
and cj was sacked and harassed by the
guy that he stood next to on the stage
which was a little interesting yeah uh
and the guys in the show sort of made
light of that which i don't think
everybody loved
we did talk about desmond's desmond i
mean
i i think that it was it was an
interesting dynamic in that room and and
you know they're not going to face each
other in the playoff but you obviously
got aiden and bryce perhaps on a
collision course and and then cj off to
the rose bowl so yeah it's
it gets a little they got along well but
um but yeah it was it was a night for
michigan folks to kind of puff their
chest out and someone to be expensive i
would say but it's been a long time
coming well i mean what was it like in a
commercial break did jim and uh ryan uh
just shake hands
chatty what happened didn't even occur
you know you said i i nick's over on one
side naruto's over there the coaches
were sort of but yes they did
them next to each other
i didn't see them like chatting it up in
the commercial breaks no i did not see
that okay yeah i'm just wondering if
there was any interesting uh asides
because i'm sure it's so quiet in there
that you could you could hear a pin drop
certainly if uh jim and ryan are gonna
be talking during a commercial plan yeah
i i guess i don't think i i i go over
and say hello to each coach
and each set of parents it's not easy to
do that before the show so in the breaks
and in and around the show i try to make
pay my respects everybody and it didn't
even occur to me actually that the it
wasn't just horrible i think the
hutchinson's family was sitting right
behind him
literally breathing down their neck
a lot of that saturday
oh boy chris fowler here on the rich
eisen show okay so you are you and herb
street uh and the rest of your crew are
calling the orange bowl correct it'll be
correct you'll be calling michigan and
georgia
very
okay so they've never played since 65
man do you know that wolverines
and george haven't played they've only
played twice and the last time was in 65
wow i did not know i think this is a
first year coaching went up to the big
house and neither school was any good
there both also ran's in their
conference it's amazing they never
connected
on you know the capital one outback or
the various balls big ten faces sec they
haven't played which is kind of an added
layer of cool just to see them on the on
the field together right and so uh what
do you how do you think just again uh
having no and knowing these schools and
obviously knowing the sport uh the
match-up what do you think that that
looks like first blush for you chris
defensive low scoring vegas has got as
one of the lowest scoring games you'll
see at this level cfp games have been
known for wild shootouts basically in
the era when clemson and alabama and lsu
brought these big offenses in i think
it's a different feel this year you know
cincinnati and alabama be slightly
higher scoring but you know both both
teams sort of want to be physical and
run the ball and i think it comes down
to which quarterback is going to be able
to make plays you saw mcnamara make some
beautiful throws against ohio state take
advantage of the play-action
opportunities press the ball when needed
take care of the football which is what
he has to do against georgia and then
stetson bennett looked really average
against alabama after looking good for a
lot of the year at least in the metrics
in the analytics i always felt like this
is no slight on him i mean it's hard not
to be insulted by this but i just felt
like
limitations were going to come into play
at some point when the quarterback had
to make plays and alabama didn't give
him any breathing room came after him
and he looked he struggled big time in
that game so michigan can make him
uncomfortable
again i like like the chances
i think that um you know mcnamara it
really is as simple sometimes as
quarterback play right in these games
because i think they're pretty evenly
matched and they're both physical and
they both want to do the same things and
then you know uh in the other game i
imagine you know you knowing saban as
well as possible the amount of rat
poison that he refers to
in the normal sense this week the the
last time was yummy because he was on
the opposite side
of the conversation i imagine cincinnati
coming in and playing alabama the amount
of rat poisoning he's going to be like
the exterminator he's going to be just
uh trying to make sure that nothing gets
through i don't know themselves though
when you look as good as they did
against georgie everybody's like oh yeah
yeah why why was bama in underdog again
why did we doubt them i mean they just
that was that was emphatic
and and comprehensive so they go into
this game as a big favorite and i'm
going to be interested to see how fickle
and cincinnati approach this i mean do
they
act like this is a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity we were never going to come
this way again we've got to in order
they go out and play with a little bit
of abandon and freedom and i i think
that would help
because the playoff deal is different
and teams that have not experienced it
and don't know how to approach it
and whereas alabama all those players
have been in multiple playoff games and
championship games and so on it's really
you know how it is in the nfl it's just
different it's a different level of
intensity and so you say
it's just a regular game you approach it
the same okay
go ahead good luck with that it doesn't
really work if you don't match
the intensity of alabama right away and
send a statement early
these games get away from people in a
big hurry we've seen it so many times in
the semi-final games and they they will
come out swinging and since he better be
ready to match it early and hang with
them if they do
if they hang with him can make it a
close game
um i know desmond ritter is more than
capable of causing alabama a lot of
problems but
you just survived the opening rounds and
heavyweight comes out flailing chris
fowler here on the rich eisen show i'll
give you the floor uh i've spoken to you
since the uh lincoln reality usc and
then brian kelly to uh lsu moves went
down um you know the conversation being
uh that it's just the latest example in
my mind of i don't want to hear a player
a person complain about a player not
playing in a bowl game if coaches are
allowed to do something like brian kelly
does every right to to do what he did
notre dame was potentially going to play
in the college play a football playoff
when he did that uh so what are your
what's your sense on uh the topic du
jour in college football yeah no i don't
like the direction the sport's going in
that respect i think it's it's
irreversible um basically i i think the
fluidity um is is hard to stop with the
transfer portal coaches movement a
couple things happen one on the coaching
front oshiran getting fired was a
chilling thing for coaches because two
years ago he's walking on water at lsu
two years later he's out of a job and it
can happen that fast so i think people
feel like well if they could do that to
one of their own
brian kelly goes out to lsu knowing he's
gotta win because culturally it's a
weird fit you know he's had i'm sure
you've talked about some awkward moments
trying to transition to the bayou which
is a unique wonderful place but i i've
talked to many coaches over the years
you've been outsiders there whether it's
dinardo or my archer
if you're not from there and you don't
get the culture you just have a shorter
rope so
brian knows he needs to win um you know
lincoln riley to me
listen i mean
no offense intended norman oklahoma but
if you have a chance to be in la
and and resurrect usc i think he feels
like he's gone as far as he can in
oklahoma they didn't win a championship
on a playoff game but headed to the sec
um it's going to get even more
challenging i think he sees a chance to
to immediately inject life into
recruiting at usc which has been kind of
um
untapped for a while they have not
recruited the way they've needed to let
guys go but just look at these
california quarterbacks look at look at
cj stroud and bryce young
la guys rich they're from right there
right naji harris i mean like honestly
if you you you're on and on you could
take all these kids you know some of the
best players from alabama right now and
had they not been poached from you uh
from southern california they'd stayed
put
you know you're not just losing guys to
oregon or somewhere else in the pack 12
you're losing him to cut schools across
the country right and so i think he he
comes in obviously i'm able to flip a
couple guys and i think he'll
look there's a value in being younger
and hipper on the recruiting trail right
and that's what notre dame sort of got
when kelly leaves marcus treatment gets
promoted all of a sudden you've got a
younger hipper energy and there's value
in that in 2021 in terms of the
recruiting climate so i think lincoln
will do well at usc i really do i think
he's a guy they feel like
will
make big upgrades in recruiting and make
a difference on saturdays i think that's
what they're looking for a lot of times
in coaches who can who can call the
place as he does and and literally make
a difference during the game
and and a ceo type coach
is less able to do that
uh but but lincoln is is the guy that
runs the offense and so for better or
worse it's his show and i i think that
he's got a great brand and right now
it's hot and i'm not surprised he made
the move so uh after the um
college football playoff semifinal
orange bowl you're you and kirk are
going to call the rose bowl right you're
going to be out here and passing indeed
all right taking a very fast plane okay
sleeping and then we just never want to
miss the chance to call the rose bowl
when there's an opportunity we're asked
to do it so i think that uh it's an
intriguing game i hope ohio state's
receivers like garrett wilson and
crystal lobby decide to play i think
it's very much up in the air right now
which would be a bummer i mean we talked
about that um you're not setting out the
gasparilla ball though you're sitting at
the rose bowl sort of a different deal
when you're
a big ten team and i i
it's their decision to make you gotta
respect it whatever it is but it will
impact the game but yeah we're pumped to
get out there utah will bring everybody
and utah will be very pumped up and be
nobody opting out for them i don't think
no and then and they'll be before so
right and the the the uh it's
geographically sound as well so there
there will be a large uh utes contingent
that'll be there you got the national
championship game and then uh in between
is it you're you're calling uh
an nfl game is right is that what you're
doing
you say that with a quiz
i am not i'm just saying because i i
don't know if you have time to do all
this chris that's what i'm saying
i i we're gonna find you great doing the
monday night game uh pittsburgh and the
giants see i even remember what the
matchup is at first glance it seems like
a lot that we espn has two
nfl games on the saturday week 18 right
and obviously we only have the one main
crew those guys will do their thing and
um we'll get we'll get i guess the
second pick of the game we don't know
what that's going to be at because it
depends on obviously what playoff spots
are up in the air it seems like as you
pointed out a minute ago almost
everybody's in the playoff race so it'd
be hard to imagine these games not
having some impact on week 18 almost
everywhere you go but yeah it's cool i i
love the nfl i'm a fan of it um
we had a great experience it was it was
right after the us open so it was a
bizarre preparation just like this one's
going to be
but um we'll find out the last minute
we'll get at the speed best we can and
we'll do the game we'll get into plane
and go to indy and and uh
two days later called the champions uh
that's what i'm saying you got you gotta
that's
that's what i'm saying it's your it's
your itinerary i was being quizzical
about chris not your your nfl bonafides
so we will i will be
i will be trying to get ahead on prep
and sleep between now and then but it's
going to be fun come on yeah of course
let me get your nfl juices flowing by
asking you a question right here
perhaps lost amongst the fact that you
were hosting the heisman trophy ceremony
on saturday was a story that came out on
nfl.com about urban meyer in
jacksonville right now and there's a big
to-do going on right there because the
piece was saying at one point he sat his
coaches down
and made them defend their resumes
against his to show why they should be
brought back next year and you know
that's uh that's an outlier to say the
least here in the professional ranks is
there is there um a sense that that that
that his handling of the losses here in
in the nfl is the way that he would
maybe handle the outlier of one single
loss at the college level and that might
be the disconnect here
uh chris there's probably several
challenges for him to adapt and adjust
and the players too i mean i you know
you can come in and be a drill sergeant
from day one and you can imagine how
that might not go over well if you're
losing every right right you know this
if you win everything's fine
that that's a tonic for all the problems
but when you lose everything is
amplified and i don't know the exact
tone of those meetings defending their
resume versus his if you're going to put
it that way that doesn't sound very good
no that's how it went down but
you know and making them justify their
job that doesn't sound very good but who
knows exactly how it went down i i think
that
look i mean head coaches are always
going to look to fix things
and and
give themselves a chance to keep the job
many many
many guys fire coordinators and then yes
when that doesn't fix the problem guess
who's next so
but i always thought that it might be a
bit of an adjustment for him to drive on
for the players on that side of things
too and i don't know you tell me was the
deck that stacked against jacksonville
from the start i don't know well i i
don't know i mean you you have uh called
pretty much uh every
one of trevor lawrence's big college
football games you saw him as
generationally talented as he is right
in front of you and you also called a
ton of great urban games i'm just
wondering based on what you knew of both
of them the way that he would run a
program
you know in columbus or even before that
in florida and knowing lawrence if if uh
if anything that i just told you from
that article rings true of what he would
do in columbus i guess is the way i
should have more artfully asked the
question of you i think it's tough there
i think it's tough for players and
coaches because you're right about the
parallel you don't lose games in college
like like they're losing yeah you lost
more games by far in this season than
watching a career or you've got to go
back years and years how many losses the
jags have now 11. and he had nine at
ohio state that's it yeah exactly so
there's your answer i mean he's just not
built for losing he never has
lost like this and then the players
haven't either so i you know you know
the sport is just damned hard and when
you're losing it's even harder on all
fronts and i don't think urban suffers
loss as well at all it's one of the
reasons why he was so driven and so good
in college but like i said i don't know
if it's going to work i don't know if
the deck was stacked i don't know what
what to make of it but
um i don't think anybody imagined that
going going this badly do you no i think
they only have them making the playoffs
i mean nobody did right but i mean in
terms of
they're going to finish with what 13
losses 14 losses i think so i think the
one thing we can guarantee is those
saturday games that uh that espn is
going to have is is
basically not going to include
jacksonville because i think this is i'm
fine with that
i'm more than fine with that listen you
know one of the things we were so
spoiled though rich i mean these
broadcast teams in the nfl like you go
in and even a big game involving a
marquee opponent right you might have
the other side as four and eight or
something right so you gotta go and do
the meetings when things are going south
we don't have that problem in college
everyone we call they're having it's a
big game they're having a great season
it's tough to go in there you know
hopefully
we do the week 18 we'll have some great
meetings with people and there'll be
a lot to play for and you know you
mentioned like the cardinals game like
what's cool about the league is you can
suffer a bunch of losses i happen to
like the parody of it i think it's one
of the weaknesses of college football at
the moment it's just so top-heavy this
year less so it was nice to see some
fresh faces winning conference titles
and and and have some fresh faces in the
playoffs but the nfl like like arizona
like if they're a third if they're third
in the conference you gotta you gotta go
through tampa good luck with that i mean
it's so there's so much at stake like a
monday game with a few weeks to go i
like that i like that part of it yeah
and and guess what you and kirk for
those conversations you're the fresh
face i guarantee you because it's week
18 right so
you're going to be calling the national
championship game a couple days later
the first several minutes of your zoom
or your meeting will be them picking
your brain about what you think is going
to happen in the game i guarantee you
that's what's going to happen you know
they're going to be excited maybe i know
their time is precious i i don't know i
bet you uh i think it's it it is it is
kind of neat when you come in you get
the rare chance and we've only done the
one game but we've also i i bump into
plenty of nfl people you know on the
scouts and so on and personnel people
around at games and it is kind of neat
you're not one of the ones who are
bugging them and harassing them every
week so
it's nice to be a fresh face and
absolutely they're a little bit eager to
talk to you which which is pleasant yeah
i mean if you get belichick you'll talk
saban with him you get kyler you can
talk about oklahoma i mean you and kirk
have quite the rolodex to be talking
with all of these guys i need to have a
conversation with mayok on the field in
vegas at the packfilm championship game
about kayvon thibodeaux you know versus
hutchinson
pass rushers what they look for what's
crucial about about how a team views
them i mean that we don't smother our
college broadcasts in
what what their draft board position is
because i think you can overdo that it's
a college game we're not talking about
um
we're not talking about the next level
essentially but it is fun for me to hear
their perspective on right there's a lot
of value in how we present it based on
you know how these guys are viewed from
personnel yes chris great to chat with
you say hello to jennifer how's the pod
doing what's going on
um it's good we have we have uh you know
who jen welter is the first female coach
in the nfl
with the cardinals she is our brand new
guest and she's talking about
a lot of stuff you know coaching and
from from a very different perspective
she is the current guest and lance
armstrong was the one before her so it's
going well thank you i appreciate it
fowler who you got the where all
podcasts are required and you go back
with lance to the scholastic sports
america days on espn don't you it's a
conversation we've never had and there's
a friendship i can tell you that this
was it was a very interesting deep dive
in the stuff we've never gotten into so
okay it was cool where all podcasts can
be acquired check that out chris you
chat you take care of yourself we'll
chat together and susie happy holidays
right back at you the great chris fowler
everybody right here on the rich eisen
show of that guy
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here